here comes the ball screen from Draymond
Green on the switch Cleveland has Curry
shot clock at five Ferry behind the back
tries gets all the way to the basket
gets an easy layup and it's a
three-point lead
and it's the seal in the middle of the
lane by Draymond Green that cleared out
any weak side help green on him
lob inside the donchic underneath the
basket got to put it up he does Miss
This
Thompson saves it and Looney foul with
1.7 seconds left they were going for the
two doncics couldn't handle the pass
then missed the shot I actually don't
think they were going for the two I
think the way green played on the top
side
was a read for for donchic and just
smart basketball
just couldn't convert
and now Looney has a chance to put it
away he's two for four at the line
tonight 59 percent